here now with more on the serious
ongoing situation at the southern border
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham it
always amazing as you watch first you
see these statistics in the Obama years
and all the times they use tear gas did
you do remember any reports any hysteria
from the media about that well number
one no and how long does it take you to
figure this out when it comes to Obama
when he's his tear gas he's protecting
the country the narrative is that Trump
is a cruel heartless bastard only works
if he uses tear gas on kids and it
undercuts the argument if of the Obama
administration used tear gas to protect
our our border from being overrun the
question for the country is what do you
say to the people who shot the canisters
I stand behind the men and women on the
border standing between us and people
who want to cross illegally when you're
slamming the tear gas you're slamming
the people we put on the border to
protect us and that's what disgusts me
the most what are we what are they
supposed to do yeah whereas those models
are being pelted at them Oh what are we
supposed to do when they're breaking
down barriers and want to rush the
border this is what we were warning
about before the elections and it's now
coming to pass and there are thousands
more still coming well I've been a
lawyer in the military most of my adult
life you use the least amount of force
possible to protect you and secure the
mission and the mission is to protect
the border from being overrun so tear
gas keeps the people apart you don't get
in a fight that's a good thing the
bottom line is Donald Trump was right to
call the caravan out weeks ago he's
right to make sure it never crosses the
border people throughout the world are
watching the president if he blinks here
his credibility on securing the border
is dead
he's not going to blink into my
Democratic friends how do you expect the
public to work with us to fix a broken
immigration system if you support one
wave after another a lots at stake here
the president's not going to bend he's
not going to back
and I hope the Republicans in Congress
will stand behind it so President Obama
tear gases people on a monthly basis we
now have literally and we'll talk to
Kirsten Nielsen the Secretary of
Homeland Security we have identified
Mexico too has identified at least 500
maybe 600 criminals coming across that
border that have integrated themselves
into the migrant population and that
means when I sat through a briefing with
Rick Perry in Texas when he was governor
a security briefing that Obama should
have been at when I sat through it they
had seven year period of time 642
thousand crimes committed against Texans
some minor many serious including murder
I've interviewed angel moms and dads
more than I ever wanted to of my whole
life lost their lives to illegal
immigrants that were that we even had in
our justice system and never deported at
what point does the government bear the
responsibility that they didn't do their
job and enforce the law what capability
they have well I think we have a lot of
culpability as a nation from ignoring
this problem you know doing the same old
thing and expecting a different outcome
is insanity President Trump is going to
stop the caravan the next ones coming
won't come if this one is stopped he'll
shut down the border if he has to
Democrats should give him the money he
needs to secure the border if they deny
him the funding to secure our border
President Trump is going to push back
and fight back and this is a day of
reckoning for the American people what
message do you want to send to the rest
of the world about our border if you
want to be open borders this is your
chance if you want to stand firm this is
also your opportunity and I hope
Democrats understand you got a really
hate Trump to not see this care events a
problem for the American people let me
ask you last question about Muller
president said he's not going to stop
this never had any plans he said it been
numerous times now at this point how do
we justify as a nation if that believes
in our constitutional republic we agree
in equal application of our laws equal
justice under the law
and Hilary used paid for phony Russian
lies to influence the American people
that was used as a fraud on the Pfizer
port would never verify to corroborated
Hillary never identified as having paid
for it and then it goes further then
it's used as part of a leak strategy the
bulk of information according to yours
and Charles Grassley's memo used to
obtain the FISA warrants where's why has
Muller if he cares about Russian
interference she paid for it why is that
not an issue well you can't blame Muller
because it's not his charter to look at
that I do blame the door why is it not
if he's looking for Russia collusion why
is that not within his mandate when
somebody's loan application is within
his mandate well it might be but I blame
the Department of Justice for not
appointing a special counsel to look at
the FISA warrant they really got away
with a lot here and if I'm chairman of
the committee next year we're going to
look at the FISA warrant problem I
promise you we will you're gonna get to
the bottom of that you all so could we
get to the bottom of Hillary's emails
and destruction of emails we need a
special counsel to look at all this why
was the FBI in the tank for Clinton did
they have a political bias this screams
for a special counsel that's why I Trump
was so upset with the sessions
Department of Justice Lindsey Graham
senator thank you for being with us